you know by the time I was 10 11 12
years old I was playing in arenas that
were selling out that's crazy you like
circuses in town a little bit and not
like that but I mean but in those days
too it was such a big world because
there was no internet there was no cell
phones and so a kid might be 3 hours
away and you would hear about him and
then when you play against them my dad
would be in the car and after the game
he would say to me his favorite mind was
always no matter how good you think you
are there's somebody out there better
than you and I'd say okay and even when
I was 15 16 when people said okay he's
going to be a professional hockey player
my dad never one time said you know oh
he's a c miss or he's going to make it I
mean he hoped because he knew how much I
loved it but he never pressured me the
only thing he pressured me about is he
would call me say you didn't miss any
classes today so he oh yeah he I said
dad I don't miss class because because
if I miss class the team so I was
playing Junior Hockey and it was hard
cuz we practice every day and we travel
a lot yeah and so they were the team was
always on you like you better be in
class so he was more concerned that I
was in class I remember I was uh 17 and
I had this uh school teacher and he it
was I was taking a physics class and I
hated physics and chemistry was I kept
thinking now where is this going to
where am I going to use this in the
world yeah that's all I kept thinking um
anyway and he said if you just put the
work in I'll pass you so I did I went to
class I went to an extra class every day
with him and he worked an extra half
hour every day he passed me and that was
the year that month I got offered to
turn pro and I signed a pro contract and
I remember I came back and I I bought
him a gift it wasn't a whole it wasn't a
big thing it was like a briefcase or
something thanking him for not for being
so patient with me and being so nice to
to me he was so grateful and it was
always sort of when I signed my dad said
you're going to stay Pro Hockey you're
going to stay in high school till your
18 I don't care what you do but you're
going to school till your 18 so here I
am playing pro hockey and going to high
school I was picking up my teammate's
daughter we were in the same class no
way the guy's name was Jim neelson and I
would pick his daughter up we were in
the same school same class then I go to
practice you were like ice V Presley so
the principal called me in one day and
he said son I don't know you're not
going to amount to anything you're
missing too many
classes I'm like well and he said you
know I should just kick you out and I
said listen it was like early January
and I said listen do me a favor and he
goes what I said give me till January 26
and if I haven't changed my ACT by then
you can kick me out but I knew I
couldn't go to class cuz we're always
traveling and playing I was playing pro
hockey playing in Quebec City and going
to Cincinnati and do you have an ego
were you in we like The Fawns at this
point in class I sat in the back corner
I just minded my own business so the day
I turned 18 I walked into the principal
and I said I just want to thank you for
not K kicking me out but I quit I'm done
and I quit school and my I said I called
my dad and and my dad said well you
promise me you'd stay at 18 cuz the
contract wasn't valid unless he would
sign it unless your father would sign it
cuz I wasn't 18 yet wow and so he said
I'll sign it but you got to stand school
so did you ever finish High School
technically um no but I'm a doctor
yeah does that mean anything I'm an
honorary doctor um it counts to me bro
so if you get most of the 12 grades I
think that's a lot people are always
like you got to do all of them yeah um
I'll give you an example when I was 15
years old I was playing on a junior
hockey team and it was so exciting
because my one of my teammates was
Murray how who was Gordy how's youngest
son oh wow and he's just a wonderful kid
and I wore number nine that year cuz I
always loved Gordy and so when he came
in I said look you should wear number
nine your dad's Gordy house which my
number and he goes no no no no this is
Wayne this is my last year of hockey um
I'm going to enjoy it and I go okay he
goes I'm going to be a doctor he was a
really intelligent guy and he did go on
to become a doctor so we get on the team
bus and we travel to the
city he he' get on there and he'd have
all these books right and I'd get on no
books and he goes Wayne you got you got
to get your education you got to I go
I'm going to a hockey game I can't think
about reading right now and doing
homework and so about two weeks later I
got on the bus and I had like five or
six books I sit down beside him and he
he goes good to see you're taking notes
Here Wayne that's good good for you and
he said he goes what do you got
geography history I go well I got Gordo
hockey my away Gordy how hockey tips I
said you want to be a doctor Christmas
you want to be a doctor I want to be a
hockey player Gordy was so nice he was
just so it was a dinner it was a charity
dinner this is an incredible story uhhuh
and 700 people were at the dinner and
that was the year I scored 400 goals so
the city wanted me to be part of it and
you know when you're 10 years old you
can't even stand up and do a speech in
front of your classmates right so they
had told the guy so you're only 10 at
this time yeah so they told the MC Wayne
just introduced him he's not going to
talk and so um Joe thyman was
there yeah Gordy how when you were 10
yeah Sandy Holly a famous jockey and so
they all get up and they kind of talk
for seven or eight minutes and people
laugh and giggle so the guy announces my
name and I'm like oh no and I'm already
Frozen and Gordy says to me now listen
when you go up there just tell them
you're lost that your skates and your
hockey stick and so I got okay okay so I
get up there and I was shaking and I I
remember I said Thank you and I started
balling I got a standing ovation I went
and sat
down do you remember like the first date
you ever went on when you were a kid or
something like that oh really hockey was
my life it was huh it was your
girlfriend I didn't have one just hockey
yeah just you know I had a um Junior a
coach when I 16 years old playing with
19 20 year olds and he would say playing
Junior Hockey is really hard
um but being a professional hockey
player is a great life and so you said
you got hockey you got um uh schooling
and you got uh night life and you can
only do two of the three so make sure
you pick the right two so when you're 16
years old it was my life I loved lived
and died it go to school from 8:30 to
3:00 practice 4:00 to 6 every night play
usually Thursday Saturday Sunday back to
school same things same rou when you
when you see like how you were compared
to like how some other players were
right did you think that you almost had
like a uh abnormality how much you liked
it or how much you focused on it like
was it that kind of thing um because I
see players I have friends that are good
at things and friends that really are
let's put it this way um I know there's
a lot of other really good players and
athletes but for us for me you know
especially when I got to be 16 I knew I
knew that was my life like I knew it
wasn't going to be a great student um I
knew it was going to be hard for me to
get a college degree I I understood that
I knew my forte was going to be hockey
and growing up playing baseball tracking
field lacrosse and I encourage parents
all the time all those Sports helped my
hockey oh yeah and so by the time I got
to 16 I was like okay this is what I'm
going to do I I want to be a
professional hockey player um and so I I
really that was my focus and the only
advice my dad used to say give me really
was um you got a great opportunity here
to really have a wonderful life and the
good Lord blessed you with a love and a
passion like I've never seen before and
sort of like don't blow it don't throw
it away and so I always kind of thought
that that I never thought I was missing
out going to a different city or going
here or doing this if I was my enjoyment
was being on the ice yeah I didn't think
I was missing anything else like wow I
never even never even phased me yeah
that the thing and you know I can
remember
um my dad saying you know you're going
to have so many opportunities here for
some reason you know with your aunt
being down syndrome and you growing up
with that and the Canadian Institute for
the blind was in my hometown of Branford
like there's more than just hockey like
you're going to be one day you're going
to be a symbol for good things and so I
always I kind of grew up with it right
it was that was kind of my education
what a powerful thing to say to a child
too you know that they have the that
they if they do their bet you know not
even do their best but if
they help people they make enough effort
that they have a the possibility to be a
a symbol for for good and so that's
really powerful yeah and so you know I
just I that's I guess you know I became
Wayne Gretzky and so just had a love for
it that's all is it hard like did it
trust trust me there was a lot of guys
with more Talent than I had right
there's a lot of guys who were better
than I was really and then there's some
guys that I just wanted it more than
yeah but by by no means was I the best
player ever there was so many great
players I'm fine I'm happy with what I
accomplished I'm happy I'm I did it I'm
happy I'm done but that's all kind of
behind me now I don't worry about it
it's it's like uh I get parents who come
up to me you you know mothers are
hardest right and my mom was worse too
She chased down Bobby Hall to get an
autograph for me and and so when moms
grab me I go I get it I get it my mom
did it for me too but the moms always
say to me will you tell my son how many
hours a day he used to practice and I go
that's not it and she go what do you
mean I go that's not it I said I just
did it cuz I loved it if you have to say
you got to be out there two hours or 3
hours you're in the wrong thing I just
was there all day long because I loved
it